as you probably know the Hebrew Bible
known as the Old Testament by Christians
was mainly written in Hebrew the
language of the ancient Hebrews 99 of
the Bible was written in this ancient
form of the language that we now call
Biblical Hebrew but you may not know
that the remaining one percent was
written in a different language Aramaic
Aramaic was widely spoken throughout the
Assyrian Empire which conquered the
kingdoms of Judah and Israel in the 8th
century and expelled the people of
Israel who became the ten lost tribes
and never returned it was also widely
spoken throughout the Babylonian Empire
which conquered the remaining Kingdom of
Judah and sent its population into Exile
the Jews who were taken into captivity
by the Babylonian Empire learned Aramaic
and the Aramaic sections of the Bible
were written shortly after that time
there have been many stages of the
Aramaic language with distinct features
but the Aramaic of the Bible is based on
Imperial Aramaic the lingua Franca of
much of the Middle East during Assyrian
and Babylonian times and an official
language of the akimenid Empire after it
annexed the Babylonian Empire and 539
BCE
Aramaic gradually replaced Hebrew as the
common language spoken by Jews in the
ancient Middle East and a tremendous
amount of Jewish religious literature
has been written in Aramaic while there
are distinct languages with many
differences Aramaic and Hebrew are
closely related and you could even say
sister languages they both belong to the
Northwest branch of the Semitic language
family though Hebrew belongs to the
Canaanite sub-branch along with
Phoenician while Aramaic forms its own
sub-branch in the Hebrew Bible and other
Jewish writings they are both written in
the same square script which is a
variation of the Aramaic script which
was developed by Jews after the
Babylonian exile the original Hebrew
script was different and is now referred
to as the paleo-hebrew script and was
essentially identical to the Phoenician
script imprinted Bible texts both
languages use the same system of vowel
markings which were added to the
original text centuries later by Jewish
scribes known as the massarites both
languages have the same system of word
formation word roots usually consisting
of three consonants which are added into
templates patterns of affixes and vowels
which add meaning to the root for
example biblical hebrewton and biblical
Aramaic
nouns which mean power sovereignty or
Dominion they both have the root Shin
lamethlete but around those three root
consonants are vowels and a suffix that
form the word
another example the verb form
and which usually means I write or I
will write since this is the imperfect
conjugation there are three root
consonants
and around those consonants are the
first person singular suffix vowel
markings and the dots known as a dagesh
inside the second root consonant to
indicate that it's pronounced as a stop
rather than as a fricative to rather
than
you can see that the templates often
differ somewhat between the two
languages but the system works the same
way this is characteristically Semitic
and is how Arabic works as well the two
words we just looked at are very similar
in either language in general a lot of
words in biblical Aramaic and Biblical
Hebrew are cognates equivalent words of
the same origin some words are exactly
the same the word for house is in both
languages the word for I the word for
stone the word for wisdom
the word for lion and so on but in many
other cases the words are almost the
same but slightly different the word for
hand in Biblical Hebrew is yav in
biblical Aramaic it's yav almost the
same but the vowel is slightly different
though in modern Hebrew these two vowel
markings are pronounced the same the
word for head in Biblical Hebrew is Rosh
in biblical Aramaic it's
Biblical Hebrew and biblical Aramaic are
different because they developed
differently throughout their history
we'll see some more examples of that in
a minute but first let's look at a
different aspect of History our own
family's history I partnered with the
sponsor of today's video myheritage DNA
to help me discover more about my own
history and genetic Origins a few weeks
ago I received this beautiful DNA
testing kit from my Heritage the
unboxing is easy and intuitive and the
simple DNA cheek swap test only takes
about two minutes after that you send
your DNA sample to the myheritage lab
and get your results three to four weeks
later the results include an ethnicity
estimate with the percentage breakdown
of your genetic ancestry across 42
different ethnicities and over 2 000
geographic regions so it's time for me
to look at my results for the first time
and see if I learn anything new or
surprising about my own genetic history
okay so here I am on the website I'm
going to click view results and see what
we discover all right here we are I am
62.1 English
34.9 north and west European and two
percent Scandinavian all right that's a
little weird
um my name is a Danish name so I always
thought I would have more Danish
ancestry than two percent
um but I guess that depends on how your
name gets passed down so Scandinavian
being only two percent that's a little
bit of a surprise but this one is a
complete wild card I had no idea about
this Middle Eastern one percent I have
no idea how I have Middle Eastern
ancestry
um but I guess someone from the Middle
East must have migrated to Europe and
become part of my family at some point
in history up here there's also
something called DNA matches let's see
what that's all about okay so on this
page they also give me a whole bunch of
DNA matches these are people who are
related to me but I don't know who these
people are so let's have a look for
example this person is my second
cousin's daughter this next person is my
parents second cousin uh and this person
is my third cousin it's interesting that
over here you can see just how much of
your DNA you have in common 2.2 percent
for this person
wow this was really interesting just
like the historical development of
different languages and dialects is so
fascinating it's also fascinating to
look at your own historical development
and your own ethnic and Geographic
Origins so I think you would really
enjoy taking a DNA test from myheritage
and learning more about your own
background buy a DNA kit using the link
in the description or pinned comment use
my coupon code langfocus for free
shipping as an added bonus you can start
a 30-day free trial of myheritage's best
subscription for family history research
and enjoy a 50 discount if you decide to
continue it get ready to make myheritage
a historic part of your journey now
let's talk about some more differences
between Biblical Hebrew and biblical
Aramaic sometimes there are recurring
differences because of historical
developments in either language Biblical
Hebrew is a Canaanite language which
underwent the Canaanite Vowel Shift in
which long A-Class vowels shifted to O
class vowels in other words awe shifted
to O for example the word for good in
biblical Hebrew is Tov while in biblical
Aramaic it's the word for no in Biblical
Hebrew it's LOL while in biblical
aramaicates law
the word for peace in Biblical Hebrew
it's shalom while in biblical Aramaic
it's shlom
there are also recurring differences
between certain consonants because
earlier Semitic consonants developed
differently in either language words
that have Shin pronounced in Biblical
Hebrew sometimes have Tao pronounced in
biblical Aramaic for example the word
for snow Hebrew and Aramaic the word for
three Hebrew and Aramaic cloth
words that have Zain pronounced Z in
Biblical Hebrew sometimes have Dallas
pronounced or the in biblical Aramaic
for example the word for gold in Hebrew
and Aramaic de hav the word for beard in
Hebrew
and Aramaic the Khan
words that have salty pronounced in
Biblical Hebrew sometimes have plait
pronounced in biblical Aramaic for
example the word for summer in Hebrew
and in Aramaic
other words that have salty in Biblical
Hebrew sometimes have thine in biblical
Aramaic for example the word for earth
in Hebrew eres and in Aramaic and it
also has an alternate form with the
letter
being aware of these corresponding
sounds can help you identify cognates in
the other language
the personal pronouns in either language
are similar but most are somewhat
different for example the word for I in
Hebrew is Ani or while in Aramaic it's
Anna the word for we in Hebrew is
while an Aramaic it's and so on the
prepositions of both languages are
mostly the same and work in the same way
the word for two or four is look in both
languages
or Daniel the word for in or with is in
both languages
with wisdom the word for like or as is K
in both languages and so on in terms of
grammar there are a few differences
between the two languages that stand out
the definite article meaning the is
different in either language in Hebrew
the letter hey is prefixed to the word
usually with the vowel ah with some
exceptions and it adds that dot we saw
before called a dagesh to the following
consonant wherever possible which causes
gemination in other words it doubles the
consonant
means the heavens or the sky
in Aramaic the letter alef with the
vowel ah before it is suffixed to the
null in other words it comes at the end
of the noun
there's something interesting to note
about these nouns themselves in both
languages they're always plural even
when they refer to heaven or the sky in
a singular sense and I know someone's
going to say that they're actually in
the Dual form but they're not they just
look like it because the singular form
ends in a yod
the basic indefinite form of the Aramaic
word is shmain while in Hebrew it's
the regular masculine plural in Hebrew
is IM while an Aramaic it's in the
regular feminine plural in Hebrew is
oath while in aramaiah gets on the
Hebrew word for gift is
and its plural is Matthau North the
Aramaic word is and its plural is
matanon dual forms differ in the same
way that masculine plural nouns do
earlier we saw the Hebrew noun meaning
hand it has the Dual form
the Aramaic word has the Dual form
yazayin
the way of expressing existence is
different in Hebrew the particle
indicates existence it means there is or
there are in biblical Aramaic a
different word is used
for example Daniel 2 28 contains the
phrase
there is a God in heaven word for word
there is a God in heaven the an
equivalent Hebrew sentence might be yes
word for word there is a God in the
heaven note that in Aramaic the normal
word for God is Allah while in Hebrew
the usual word is Elohim the plural form
of but here I used iloa because the
sense is a singular God that hasn't been
specified yet
to show a lack of existence in Aramaic
you add the negation particle law before
ethai for example Daniel 2 10 contains
this string of words
there is no man in Hebrew you use a
different word in place of yish
in Hebrew an is also used to negate
sentences especially with pronominal
suffixes
in the context of Isaiah 1 15 means I
will not hear
word for word it's not I hear participle
form Aramaic doesn't have this
construction so this would be an Allah
word for word it's I know here
participle form the Hebrew form could
also be anilo but in Biblical Hebrew law
is not commonly used with this type of
verb form a participle form
Biblical Hebrew and biblical Aramaic
also use a different relative pronoun
meaning which or that in Aramaic it's D
this phrase means the temple which was
in Jerusalem
word for word Temple the witch in
Jerusalem note that can mean either
Palace or Temple the Hebrew word is
word for word it's the temple which in
Jerusalem
there's also a short equivalent Shea
which prefixes to the following word so
this could be him
the Aramaic pronoun D is also used to
show a genitive relationship between
words like of let's take the genitive
phrase the gold of the king or the
king's gold this can be expressed in
three ways with a construct chain the
half of word for word gold construct
form King the with the
of King the or with d and the possessive
suffix on
word for word gold his of King the like
his gold of the king
in Biblical Hebrew construct chains are
ubiquitous
gold construct form the king
the Hebrew cognate of D is Zay but it
lost its genitive usage and only
retained its use as a demonstrative
pronoun meaning this
another way to show the genitive in
Hebrew is to use Asher literally witch
too or you could think of it as which
belongs to Hazard
word for word the gold which to the king
ashirallah also developed into the
possessive particle
this is the norm in later forms of
Hebrew including modern Hebrew but
doesn't appear in Biblical Hebrew like
the Aramaic sentence
later forms of Hebrew including modern
Hebrew have sentences like this
his gold of the king but this doesn't
occur in Biblical Hebrew and seems to be
from later Aramaic influence
one last grammatical difference I want
to mention is that biblical Aramaic does
not have the wow conversive in both
Biblical Hebrew and Aramaic the word
spelled with the letter wow means and
and sometimes but but in Biblical Hebrew
it also has the function of reversing a
verb's tense or its aspect to be more
precise take this sentence from
Leviticus 1 1.
this means and the Lord called to Moses
and spoke to him word for word it and
call in perfect form to Moses and speak
in perfect form the Lord to him in this
sentence the verb forms are in the
imperfect form which expresses an
incomplete action but the wow makes the
meaning perfect which expresses a
completed action this is a formal
literary form in Biblical Hebrew Aramaic
doesn't have this and it stopped being
used in later forms of Hebrew but in the
earlier writings of the Hebrew Bible
it's ubiquitous let's take a look at a
verse from the Bible written in biblical
Aramaic break it down and then see how
it might have been written in Biblical
Hebrew but the Hebrew sentence will be
theoretical since it doesn't actually
appear in the Bible I'm translating it
myself the verse is Jeremiah 10 11. the
whole book of Jeremiah is written in
Biblical Hebrew except for this one
verse thus shall you say to them the
gods who did not make the heavens and
the Earth Shall Perish from the earth
and from under these Heavens in Aramaic
um
foreign
next we see two equivalent verb forms
meaning you shall say in biblical
Aramaic and the Biblical Hebrew tomru
both are the second person plural
imperfect form of the verb root aleph
meaning to say they both have the same
second person prefix but with a
different vowel and they have a similar
plural suffix but the Aramaic one ends
in a noon
are their respective forms of the
preposition Le with a third person
plural pronominal suffix so it means to
them so this first part means thus you
shall say to them and then a quotation
begins in biblical Aramaic
is the plural form of the word meaning
God plus the definite article suffix so
it means the Gods in Biblical Hebrew I
used
the definite plural form of the word for
God remember that in Hebrew it can refer
to God in the singular meaning the god
of the Hebrews or gods in general which
is what it refers to here and notice
again in Hebrew the definite article is
a prefixed hey while in Aramaic it's a
suffixed alith
biblical Aramaic D and Biblical Hebrew
Asher are the relative pronouns meaning
that which or who which we saw before
Aramaic and Hebrew are the definite
plural forms of the words for heaven
that we saw before
means and in both languages Aramaic
araka and Hebrew are all this are the
words for Earth with the definite
article attached in the third consonant
letter we see one of those sound
differences that stem from different
historical developments
these two nouns are the objects of the
verb in the sentence law and law are the
negation particles that negate the
following verb Aramaic is a verb meaning
do or make in the third person plural
perfect conjugation this has a cognate
verb in Hebrew but it means to labor or
work so I used a different word which
means to do or make
in its third person plural perfect form
instead of orasu this could also be
which means they created that's the verb
used in the Book of Genesis to describe
God's creation of the Earth but I didn't
use it in this sentence because the
Aramaic sentence doesn't use its cognate
word the subject of this verb is the
gods so this whole part means the gods
who didn't make the heavens and the
Earth all of this is the subject of the
sentence in this quotation the predicate
is next Aramaic and Hebrew mean they
Shall Perish they're the third person
plural imperfect form of the verb aleph
Beth Dallas again they have the same
third person prefix and the same plural
suffix but have a different vowel
pattern
next we see the preposition mean meaning
from which also has a prefixed form in
either language in Biblical Hebrew It's
usually the Standalone form before the
definite article ha but in Aramaic you
can see it's the prefixed form here in
Biblical Hebrew it's usually prefixed to
tahoth the word meaning under but we see
the Standalone form before the
equivalent Aramaic word these nouns here
mean the Earth but notice that the
Aramaic one is different from before
this word occurs in two different
variant forms in which the third
consonant is different they're both
equivalent to Saudi in Biblical Hebrew
again we have the words for heaven or
Heavens followed by the masculine plural
demonstrative pronoun
meaning these so together these words
mean these Heavens notice that in Hebrew
it has the definite article to make it
agree with the noun while in Aramaic it
doesn't
in this case the demonstrative pronoun
is the same as the Hebrew one but in
other Bible verses a more exclusively
Aramaic form is used
the one in this verse May reflect the
influence of Hebrew or a different
Aramaic dialect
this whole predicate means Shall Perish
from the earth sent from under these
heavens
in my opinion the original Aramaic verse
and my theoretical translation into
Biblical Hebrew are quite similar there
are numerous little differences but most
words are cognates and I think a speaker
of either language would be able to
figure out what the sentence and the
other language means at least in writing
I mentioned earlier that only one
percent of the original Hebrew Bible was
written in Aramaic but there are also
translations of the entire Hebrew Bible
into Aramaic with some additional
commentary these are called targums
tagum being the Hebrew word for a
translation or translated work
they were written centuries later than
the original Aramaic parts of the Bible
but the Aramaic language used in them
doesn't seem so different to me I want
to look at a verse from the most
commonly used targum targumunclos let's
start right at the beginning Genesis 1 1
in the beginning God created the heavens
and the Earth in
Hebrews
word for word in beginning created God
direct object marker the heavens and
direct object marker the Earth and in
Aramaic because mean
is the preposition meaning in in both
languages aadmin comes from a different
root than it's the plural form of which
means earlier time bakazmin means
something like in the early days or in
the beginning days
Hebrew has a cognate word called ma
meaning Antiquity or beginning but it
wasn't used in this verse the verb
meaning he created is the same in either
language but all in Hebrew and but all
in Aramaic the difference being in the
first vowel next in Hebrew we have the
plural word Elohim meaning God but in
Aramaic the tetragrammaton is used the
proper name of God in the Bible in its
abbreviated spelling in Judaism its
pronunciation is prohibited so it's
pronounced as a different word
which can be translated as Lord this
word is used in Biblical Hebrew as well
in its full spelling
but it wasn't used in this particular
verse targums are not considered strict
translations but rather paraphrased
retellings of Bible verses which is why
cognates were often not used even though
they could have been notice that in both
languages the verb comes before the
subject the default Semitic word order
in both languages is vso the objects of
the verb come next you can see the
direct object markers I mentioned before
eighth in Hebrew and yoth in Aramaic in
both languages they come before both
objects and the second time are prefixed
with the word for and
and we've already seen the differences
between these particular nouns in a
previous sentence in my opinion this
verse is quite similar in either
language and a speaker of either
language would be able to read the other
easily as you can see Hebrew and Aramaic
are closely related languages and are
very similar at least in their ancient
forms and later medieval forms in the
targums there are numerous forms of both
Hebrew and Aramaic from different places
and time periods and those will differ
from each other in various ways modern
Hebrew is spoken in the modern state of
Israel and there are modern forms of
Aramaic spoken in some communities in
the Middle East but I'm sure they're not
very mutually intelligible partly
because of their different modern
pronunciation but lots of specific words
and features are probably very similar
and if you examine the two languages
closely the similarities will be obvious
but that's speculation because I've
never actually done it if you're
familiar with Hebrew or Aramaic either
modern or from a previous era how
similar would you say they are
and now it's time to say thanks to all
of the langfocus patreon supporters
especially the ones whose names appear
on the screen they're the top tier
patreon supporters so they deserve a
special thanks for continuing to help
make this channel possible
if you liked this video then check out
my playlist on Semitic languages you'll
find more videos like this about Hebrew
Arabic and more